street fighter 5 is pretty bare-bones  right now but at least we're getting dlc  characters and a big story mode this  summer and according to an unnamed  Capcom representative the fan-favorite  Arcade Mode might be making a comeback  the individual told Forbes the street  fighter team would have more information  share soon gamespot zone Peter Brown  reviewed the game pointing out its lack  of modes hourcade mode has been around  since the early years of Street Fighter  so it's absences definitely felt that  same Capcom representative also said  that the team is considering adding  difficulty sliders to the game's current  story mode more options and content  certainly can't hurt Street Fighter  Phibes true story mode launches in June  as free DLC that's on top of six  characters being released from March  through September keep an eye on  gamespot and when we hear more about the  return of arcade mode you will too